hey everyone Jody ever again here with
another episode of good sport this is
actually an episode that I knew we
wanted to do from the very beginning
before the show even existed because
it's something that I've thought about
probably more than anything else when it
comes to sports and that is the mental
side of the game and in particular
people tend to obsess with this idea of
being in the zone right that flow state
where everything seems to be clicking
where you kind of turn your brain off
and can just play it's this funny irony
where we spend all of this time thinking
about how to get to this place where we
can then just stop thinking and perform
so this episode looks into the Zone but
also really taught me some things about
kind of the other things around the zone
that we should really be focusing on
instead and some real concrete tricks
and skills and lessons that we can use
to try and stay at that level of Peak
Performance so I really love this
episode it starts with a very very
famous basketball player and then it
goes from there hopefully you will learn
some things along the way any way here
we go take a listen and of course you
can find good sport wherever you get
your podcasts
in sports there's a lot of talk about a
magical place called The Zone
you've probably heard of it that place
where everything clicks where no matter
the weather or the crowd or the sweat in
your eyes nothing can break your focus
where you just do everything perfectly
you sink every shot nothing can stop you
now when I think about the Zone when I
picture someone in the zone I picture
Steph Curry
Do You Believe In the Zone I do believe
in the zone because it's
the one time that everything kind of
goes autopilot
well if the greatest NBA shooter of all
time says the legend is real that the
zone is real it's more than just a
legend there's this
Synergy with everything that you're
trying to do and even your intentions
have been validated by the atmosphere
around you where
seems like everything else is going
right at the same time you kind of get
lost in that moment
I love that phrase your intentions are
validated by the atmosphere around you I
suppose if I were hitting every shot in
the NBA finals in front of a roaring
crowd I'd probably feel like my
intentions were validated by the
atmosphere as well
but look here's the thing about the Zone
almost by definition it is special and
fleeting and you can't force it you
can't control any of that it's just for
me
when it goes away it's the reflection on
the feeling you just had
I think it's just a natural experience
you can recognize when it's gone but
chasing after it is almost a guarantee
that you won't get there I don't think
you can train yourself to appreciate it
more than just you naturally do because
if you do then
you start to distract yourself from
what's actually happening so you heard
it directly from Steph Curry nice as it
is when you find yourself in the zone
obsessing over getting there and there
is a lot of obsession about the zone
that will get in the way of what you're
trying to do
so today we want to figure out what we
can control what we can train for
because even if the zone is elusive
there are still ways to perform at your
best to keep your head in the game
[Music]
my name is Jody Abigail and from the
from Ted audio Collective this is good
sports
we think about athletes getting their
bodies in shape to compete but talk to
top athletes and a lot of them will say
that the mental side of the game is the
real key to Peak Performance
it's one of the things I've thought
about most as an athlete how to get my
mind in the right place to be clear I'm
not talking about mental health or
emotional well-being athletes like
Simone biles and Naomi Osaka have
started really important conversations
about how an athlete's life on and off
the court connect and honestly those
deserve an entire series of Their Own
[Music]
what we're talking about in this episode
is the mental part of competition that
invisible force that I think shapes
every game every race every match and a
lot of times separates the winner from
the loser
[Music]
Dr Nicole detling is an expert on the
mental side of the game she's a sports
psychologist who's worked with Olympic
skiers and skaters pro baseball and
football and soccer players college
gymnasts athletes at the very top of
their Sports
when she first meets with these athletes
all they want to talk about is being in
the zone
[Music]
so when you ask people to describe what
it feels like what language do they use
interesting a lot of them will say
things like I don't remember much about
it like I just kind of was lost I wasn't
thinking I was just doing it and it was
amazing and I loved it and I want to get
there more but as she starts to work
with athletes she tries to shift their
thinking she tells them not to think
about the feeling of being in the zone
that they're trying to chase after but
instead that they should work on
building a solid and reliable skill that
skill is mental resilience being your
best self in all circumstances whatever
that looks like you know what I'm only
at 70 today but I'm going to do my best
to give that 70 mental resilience means
being able to find whatever version of
calm and focus you can even when things
aren't going your way those times when
you're trying to get your focus or
regain it when something is tugging at
your attention an unexpected move by
your opponent a mistake bad weather it's
about recover suffering from those
things to still play your best mental
resilience is not elusive or magical
it's a habit
we have these thinking processes and
patterns and skills that we're teaching
people to eventually get it to automate
so it's an automatic process rather than
having to turn on that mindset you
become that mindset and if we're going
to talk about the mindset required for
mental resilience I want to talk about a
sport that I have come to believe
requires more of it than maybe any other
sport a sport where a test of mental
resilience is baked right into the rules
by Athlon
meet Claire Egan Olympic biathlete
imagine her cross-country scheme
whizzing through the mountains of
Northern Italy consumed by the drive to
go fast in fact so consumed that she
would sometimes lose track of where she
was and go off course it did lead me
astray several times literally because I
was Notorious for getting lost
when Claire Egan would ski she'd get
lost in a sort of beautiful Haze focused
only on her arms her legs on pushing
forward
I can just focus on my body my breath
I'm pushing as hard as I can and harder
and harder as much as I can
but here's the thing biathlon isn't just
a cross-country skiing race where you
can allow yourself to get totally lost
no there's another component one that
would often trip Claire up because in
biathlon you go from flying across the
snow to a full stop
and then you take a rifle off your back
and on a shooting range that's nearly
silent you peer through a sight and you
try and shoot five targets that can be
as small as Oreos
164 feet away
and those shots it's hard to overstate
how much making the matters everything
is on the line if you miss a Target
depending on the race you either have to
ski extra laps or have minutes added to
your total race time
the pressure is immense
I grew up watching The Green Bay Packers
because my dad's from Green Bay and
probably most Americans can think of a
time when the kicker took the field and
of course there's two seconds or
something ridiculous left on the clock
and and you just know and that kicker
knows if they if they hit that kick the
right way it's going to be a win for the
team and if they don't it won't and
every
biathlon race is like that for every
competitor except for in football that
kicker didn't
Sprint up and down the sideline 200
times before having to then exactly yeah
right right
so biathlon is this test of body and
mind that's the mental puzzle built into
the rules the big test of resilience you
have to shift your brain from skiing to
shooting do it quickly keep your focus
but when Claire would fly into the
shooting range dripping with sweat
almost Delirious from her high-speed
racing her brain felt blurry and jumbled
thoughts swirling around as she tried to
slow everything down and shoot those
five Oreos
I wasn't actually Lucid enough to be
doing what I needed to do and so
sometimes I would leave the range having
missed three out of five and I'm
thinking to myself what did I just do
out there I don't even know what I did
is it true that most people missed the
last shot or people missed the last shot
more than the others the shooting
statistics for the last shot would be
worse than for the other shots but but
that's probably only if you've hit all
your other shots but what's going on
there
you know exactly what's on the line it's
easy to become distracted because you
start thinking about the outcome
it's such a distraction it's a
distraction that is being shoved in your
face and it's unavoidable so you have to
be strong in your mind you have to be
well prepared to say okay I'm distracted
now what
now what Claire was competing in major
events the world championships the
Olympics and she wanted medals she
needed to figure out a strategy for how
to handle the mental challenge at the
heart of her sport
so she made a routine
as a first step Claire tried to identify
what she called her transition area by
looking at the Racecourse she'd show up
early and plot out where on the course
she had to start shifting her mind from
I need to go as fast as I can to I need
to breathe and focus she'd pick a change
in the terrain or a landmark like a
flagpole
and physically at that point I would
bring my Pace down to a level where I'm
no longer accumulating more oxygen depth
so I'm not I'm not I don't want to be
getting any more tired than I already am
and once she got on the shooting range
she started using what she called an
emergency check to make sure that she'd
really made the transition
the last thing I need to do is sort of
like put my cheek down on my on my cheek
piece and and look out through the sides
the last thing I did before I would
lower my head is I would make sure that
I could see the target clearly with my
eyes like that I wasn't so
tired and out of it that I was like
Blurry because sometimes I was really
seeing blurry and so
I would kind of double check okay like
am I seeing the target clearly okay yeah
now I can make Intelligent Decisions
about what I'm doing on a shooting range
it was all about finding simple
repeatable cues a routine that could
consistently get her mind where it
needed to be this would also help Claire
handle the pressure of shooting
quiet that inner voice that was saying
if I hit this then then I'll have hit
all five like that's not a hopeful
thought and when you recognize oh I've
had that thought that's not helpful then
you can replace it with something that
actually is helpful like okay I had that
thought that's fine now I'm gonna take
one more breath exhale
and then do a really good job on the
trigger
keeping her mind focused on process is
how Clara learned to handle shooting
mistakes as well I asked her to tell me
about a time when she really struggled
with recovering from an error
try not to take you there every race
um
I could think one of the most painful
ones Was a Race out of World
Championships where I hit the first 17
and then missed the last three
that thing about biathletes struggling
with their Final Shots it happened to
Claire 17 in a row then missed the final
three brutal
it was a minute of time penalty per Miss
you know to be in metal contention and
then miss the last like to throw it away
in three seconds at the end of the race
was so painful
when Claire thinks back to that world
championship race she struck by how
certain she was that she'd make all her
shots in her mind it was the only
possible outcome and my third to last
shot I think was probably really really
close in fact I know it was close it was
what's called a split it was like half
in half out but it didn't the Target
didn't go down and
I got so distracted by that I it I like
I probably flinched I was so shocked
that I missed and instead of um
resetting I don't even remember taking
the last two shots you know I was not I
was distracted she lost sight of what
she had to do to shoot well like
checking the wind direction adjusting
her sights and having a steady trigger
squeeze on every shot
this process versus outcome thing I
think it's bled from Sports into the
rest of the world almost to the point of
cliche I've heard of people in office
meetings talk about focusing on process
it's worked its way into the world of
self-help books and podcasts
oh God is this a self-help podcast
but yeah focusing on process is really
really hard because there are all these
moments when outcome tries to rear its
ugly head and throw you and you have to
try and refocus on the steps you need to
take right now
but thinking back to that world
championship Claire also sees a deeper
lesson about the mindset it takes to
perform at the highest level after her
race was done she ran into a friend of
hers who at the time was the best by
athlete in the world
he'd made a similar mistake at the
Olympics
he missed his last few shots
he was kind of joking you know how badly
did you just throw away your race and
I'm like real bad real badly and I but I
said hey you know but I I think I
remember you doing it in in Korea too so
you know I'm maybe not alone even heroes
do this kind of thing and he said yeah
that's true that happened to me but I
won the next day
and that reminded me that what happens
the next day
is completely unrelated to what happened
the day before
it's a fresh slate and that's the
beautiful thing the one term I've always
taught was just sort of flush it right
something goes bad flush it and you just
move on that was oh yeah and and people
who are
awesome
at their sport are flushing a lot
can you learn and then move on and never
think about it again
okay we're 15 minutes into this episode
we just learned something flush it let's
move on
[Music]
growing up Dr Nicole detling love sports
in fact I was the first girl in my
school to play football she ended up
running track and playing basketball in
college just focused on her game wins
and losses points scored having fun with
her teammates but one day she was having
a chat with her dad my dad called me and
said did you know there's a field called
sports psychology and I said what
no Whole New World opened up eventually
it would become her career but it also
started to change the way she played one
of the first things that shifted
something she now works on with her
athletes was just a basic understanding
that the mental side of the game is
always there every time you play
physically every time you train every
time you think about your sport your
mind is involved if you don't know
what's going through your mind you're
not aware of what's helping you and
what's hurting you and quite frankly
it's not even Just Sports it's life it's
business it's performance it's
everything we do every day
and talk about something that feels like
it's worked its way into the larger
culture but just mindfulness and staying
in the moment and just going one moment
at a time I mean that's you know that's
exploded in sports but in real life too
we have we have apps you know that I try
to get us to focus on just this one
moment yeah and it's so difficult in
this world when we have so many things
pooling on our Attention our phone dings
our computer dings the TV you know we
always say in sports the most important
play is this play and then this play
there's a line in one of my favorite
books about the mental side of sports
called the inner game of tennis it goes
it is perplexing to wonder why we ever
leave the here and now here and now are
the only place in time when one ever
enjoys himself or accomplishes anything
and I think about that a lot how
performing well at anything being an
athlete being a manager being a partner
being a parent is often about giving the
present your full attention
so when athletes come to Dr detling she
convinces them that they need to work on
the mental side of the game and then she
gets the work to build that mental
resilience what I'll often do is ask
athletes okay tell me how you warm up or
what do you do between plays what do you
do what's your process and they'll say
okay at each one of those points what
are you doing mentally and most people
don't know what they're doing mentally
so then what I'll do is say okay well
here's what we've been working on so I
don't want you to change what you're
doing physically but when you do this
let's tie in that so maybe you're saying
a confident statement to yourself maybe
you're reminding yourself what your
assignment is on that play yeah I mean I
have you know memories it's one of my
favorite sort of things it's like during
a really high level game let's say
there's you know 10 people in the field
or the court or 15 people or whatever
you know if you were just like at a
super critical moment you know if you
were to look around or even close your
eyes and listen you know be like this
person's muttering to themselves this
person's singing a song this person's
tugging on their on their lucky jersey
this person is like so you know but it's
like everyone's just doing their own
little their little thing but it's you
know you take half a step back you're
like wow look at these butchers
yeah I couldn't agree more and that's
why I I that's what those are the things
that I look for when I go and hang out
with thieves is I'm looking for Baseline
so I've noticed you do this
first of all did you know you did that
second of all why are you doing that and
third of all what's happening mentally
while you're doing that if that's
something you're gonna do let's use it
let's utilize it in a positive way that
gets you ready for the next play
there are some things I do to try and
keep my mind calm and my body ready
before taking the field and ultimate I'd
always do three tuck jumps just the
little routine to Center myself I
actually don't think I've ever said this
to anyone but for like 20 years as I've
played sports or worked out I've had
this little snippet of a song that runs
through my head something I find myself
humming
turn
I have no idea what that song is but it
just shows up whenever I'm trying to get
into that flow State hundreds of times a
year for 20 years
probably owe whoever wrote that song
serious royalties
but for all my humming and Tuck jumps
I've still struggled with slipping out
of the moment
so much of mental resilience is
realizing that everything isn't gonna go
perfectly I've worked on that I've
worked on here's one of my favorite
cliches getting comfortable being
uncomfortable
the good news Dr detling says is that
you can train for that
some of the things that we've done with
some of the skiing Olympians that I've
worked with and actually I'll talk about
speed skating too is
we've not waxed their skis and they've
had to train with unwaxed skis right
with speed skating you know what your
blades aren't quite as sharp as you
would want them to be train that way
train with you know forgetting you know
there's a little tiny little tear in
your suit train without your goggles one
time that's why a lot of teams will pipe
In Crowd noise so they can't hear during
training sessions they can't hear each
other and they're working on those
things and training for those things
because at the end of the day we all
want to show up and feel great but yet
there will be comp day sometimes the
biggest competition of your life and you
show up feeling like crap
if you've trained feeling like crap then
you know you can compete feeling like
crap okay so you can train for the
uncomfortable moments train to keep some
focus when there are uncontrollable
external circumstances
but what about the internal what about
when you yourself are the problem when
your own thoughts are distracting you
that voice that pops up at all the wrong
moments telling you how badly you're
doing how much the game is slipping out
of your hands
when she was a college athlete playing
basketball this is the kind of thinking
that really tripped up Dr detling and
really propelled her to want to explore
the mental side of the game I was
basically my own living walking
self-fulfilling prophecy where I'd get
fouled and I'd be going to the free
throw line thinking oh my gosh I'm Gonna
Miss This oh I can't miss this I really
don't need to miss this ah come on
Nicole I mean listening to that I just
missed a free throw here in the studio
so I was setting myself up for failure
and assuming I was gonna fail before I
even got there and gave myself a chance
today this is a big part of what Dr
detling works on with athletes self-talk
I think we all know what self-talk is
and we can understand that she was
hurting her performance with all that
negative self-talk we get too that the
opposite is positive self-talk I can do
this I got this that kind of thing but
Dr detling thinks it's a little more
nuanced than just positive and negative
it's really about what does the talk do
for you
here's her example she's a runner and
she lives in Utah where it can get to
100 degrees in the summer but she's out
there running anyway and there will be
times that I will catch myself out there
going oh my gosh it is so hot yeah
that's true oh my gosh I'm so tired my
legs are so heavy both of those things
are true and then I start thinking oh I
could just call my husband and he can
come pick me up oh I could take the
short way home and what I'll recognize
in the moment is none of those thoughts
are helping me achieve what I'm out
there to do which is run and that's
negative self-talk I will catch myself
and Jody I will literally say to myself
Nicole you're being [__] stupid run
what it does for me in that moment is I
flip a switch and I run so in that
moment that is positive self-talk
because it's getting me to where I want
to be to do what I want to do
so yeah it's important to think about
helpful self-talk and try and keep
unhelpful self-talk at arm's distance
but easier said than done we all know
what it's like for your mind to wander
and then all of a sudden you're back at
self-doubt that unhelpful voice in your
head
this is where Dr detling introduces a
concept I hadn't really heard before
honestly my biggest takeaway from our
entire conversation neutral self-talk
neutral self-talk is basically keeping
your mind occupied and ready but not
exhausted
but I'll often tell people to do is just
in your mind commentate what you see
around you all right number 10 has the
ball they're moving up to Midfield I'm
going to run to that open space okay
they passed it to the right I'm gonna
drop back a little bit make sure this
guy's covered over my shoulder
neutral self-talk is like hold music for
your mind and when you're thinking
neutral you're not thinking negative and
your confidence can rest you can play in
neutral you can live in neutral neutral
is a great place to be
[Music]
man I wish I knew about neutral
self-talk years ago
because when I played Sports it was
rarely neutral I'd often ride a roller
coaster of emotions and often the
emotion I most felt was anger I've
always been one of those athletes fueled
by anger and a bit of animosity towards
my opponent
anyone who's played against me probably
didn't have a very fun time I often
didn't have much fun playing maybe I was
kind of a dick
but it was also hurting my game
I didn't have Dr detling all those years
ago when I was driven by anger but I
have her now
how do you handle someone
who is who's driven by that well let me
ask you let's do it let's do a little
bit of work here so how do you find that
place of anger where you like to be
how do you get there
um just get Petty but like intentionally
right but just you know or if it's a
rivalry and it's someone I know you know
use something from
a previous Mac but you know I always
find that spark
like I don't think I cheated but I would
often early in a game find a way to
scuffle with someone or talk a little
[__] or be aggrieved in some way just
something a spark to get me motivated
and fired up
okay and if we go like think of a scale
of one to ten where ten is like as angry
as you have ever been like probably
maybe even a little too far anger one is
you have zero you're just kind of there
playing what's your ideal level of anger
I mean it's definitely not a 10 right
because I think I know what it feels
like to be out of control
um and be and the diminishing aspect of
that but you know it's close an eight
eight or seven you know I can't be I
can't be at a four so let's say if it's
a if it's an eight then your ideal range
would be a seven to a nine so Eight's
where you want to be seven a little too
low but you're okay there nine a little
too high but you're okay there and so if
you get to that ten you have to have
your strategies to bring you back down
and if you're at a six or lower what are
your strategies to bring you up and it
sounds like for you beginning a game
sometimes you have to fabricate it it's
just not there naturally so then let's
go to what are your specific strategies
to fabricate that anger that's not there
inherently
right and you talked about opponents
yeah go ahead what else do you have on
that no and I mean to me you know I
think
the thing that I've always prided myself
on and I think has put me in a position
to when I've performed well performed
well is just a level of intensity and
everything and so you know it's it's the
warm-up it's the behavior on the
sideline it's maybe you know mixing up
with teammates in what feels like a way
that it's we're pushing each other up
um but you know I can't I can't just
flip the switch I kind of have to be in
this stew of intensity okay well there
you go so now you're using the word
intensity instead of anchor so which is
it
is there a difference between those
for you yeah and maybe that's maybe
that's the difference between seven and
ten right
and anger feeling like something that
you're sort of holding on to the live
wire
um and intensity feeling like something
you can ride a little bit there you go
now thinking about the difference
between those two anger can be really
hard to facilitate but intensity is a
lot easier and so even identifying the
difference between those two for you can
be incredibly powerful
listener I promise going forward I will
podcast with intensity not anger
deep breath deep
the mental side of sports it's a new
frontier
no surprise with all the money in sports
people are trying to figure out
shortcuts shortcuts to focus some kind
of magical Zone pill or resilience
wearable or whatever
athletes are experimenting with computer
simulations to train their minds there's
Research into supplements and hormones
that might calm our brains I tried to
put Steph Curry in an MRI machine during
our interview he was not having it
I want to tell you about the vagus nerve
it's a bundle of nerves we all have it
that runs up your neck and around your
ear
it connects all the way down to your
heart and your gut some people think it
might be the key to how your brain and
body interact
there's a lot of research into vagus
nerve stimulation and devices you can
wear to activate it with the goal of
relaxing your mind and body
a lot of these devices attach at your
ear and create a sort of low level sound
and vibration
there's these videos that show someone
wearing a vagus nerve stimulator they're
on a putting green and they just stand
there calmly sinking one putt after
another
fact over the last 45 seconds or so
we've been playing a version of that
sound if you're wearing headphones right
now you are likely entering the zone
try it out go take some free throws do
some raiding take a knife throw it in
the air you'll catch it by the handle
now I'm just messing with you
Dr detling says vagus nerve stimulation
might help some athletes in some sports
and seems to depend on the person in the
situation and it's hard to know how much
is Just placebo effect
it's just not that simple which is
actually what makes this so wonderful
think about how Dynamic sports are how
complicated the ecosystem of a game is
every time you go out there to compete
there's you there's your opponent
different players different plays a
different field different weather but
research is done on controlling
variables so that someone like Dr
detling can say x cos y
I will often get asked you know where's
the objective evidence or the data that
shows that what you do makes an impact
and there isn't any I don't have any
other than athletes saying that it makes
an impact coaches saying that it makes
an impact people continuing to come back
to me year after year after year or hire
me year after year after year it's
it does make an impact but we don't have
the scientific evidence to prove that
it's just not we just don't have the
capacity to study it yet Perhaps someday
we will
[Music]
I love the idea that sports are too
Dynamic to study the drama the constant
change the unpredictability
it's what can make Sports feel like life
is usually more messy than clean Lord
knows it's uncomfortable
but that's where the lessons you learn
in sports can teach you something about
the rest of your life too
[Music]
I've personally had what 10 12 surgeries
now related to sports so an athlete
comes to me with an ACL I'm like yeah I
know I've been there I got you okay
let's do this you know so whether it's
you know having those injuries or it's
having you know personal struggles I'm
on my second marriage my first husband
just walked out the door one day when my
kids were six and three and so as
horrible as that experience was and to
go through that experience it's helped
me help other people who go through
similar things
we are all so much stronger than we
think we can get through so much more
than we think and that's part of what
mental toughness is all about is not
that you're always this stud out there
but that you're pushing through whatever
it is that you're dealing with you're
figuring it out and some days it's
easier than others but you continue to
persevere
[Music]
you do your best on your worst days you
leave your mistakes behind flush it get
comfortable being uncomfortable and on
those days where everything is clicking
where you Race Across the snow and make
all your shots where you're the Steph
Curry of reading books to your kids
you just try to stay in the moment
why would we ever leave the Here and Now
here and now the only place in time when
one ever enjoys oneself or accomplishes
anything
[Music]
on the next episode of good sport
what should we do here ethically never
ever comes up when you're negotiating a
stadium deal
is there such a thing as a good Stadium
deal or maybe just a less bad one
good sport is brought to you by the Ted
audio Collective it's hosted by me Jody
evergay this show is produced by Ted
this episode was written and produced by
Camille Peterson our team includes
Isabel Carter Ponce Rush Sarah Nix Jimmy
Gutierrez Michelle Quint Ben Chang and
Roxanne High lash Jake Gorski is our
sound designer and mix engineer
fact checking by Nicole pasoka we'll be
back soon with more good sport make sure
you're following good sport and your
favorite podcast app so you get every
episode delivered straight to your
device and leave us a review We love
hearing from our listeners see you soon
[Music]